basketball when Tobago is one of the
biggest things here a lot of these kids
that's all I got is basketball
the town of wonder bagel population is
about 1,500 I want a bagel public school
it's probably at 250 there ain't a whole
lot to do here besides play basketball
basically all they got is a gym to go to
so I open it from
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
when you come play for Winnebago high
school we expect to compete every year
for a state title my name is Jeffrey
barrage and I am the head coach I
wouldn't bang a public school winters in
Winnebago it's called but everybody
knows it's Beck's boss season so that
means that the gyms hot it's good they
love basketball here is really big it
plays an important part in that
community of Native American Reza is
just our version of a really fast paced
backs ballgame
we call it Reds ball it's coming from
the reservation obviously it's a short
for red you missed the shot you missed
the shot move on I expect a lot from
these boys and I push them to be great
because I don't just want to see them
playing on this court I want to go watch
them in college that's my ultimate goal
is just to get these kids to bigger
places some of these kids have our
broken homes alcohol gambling all that
stuff comes into play on the
reservations and backs ball does say I
always tell them you take care of that
ball that balls gonna take care of you
now marking proof of it I'm from here I
played ball at the college level and
it's just what I bring to these kids and
show them that it's possible d-von the
point he's a senior guard for me so this
year he's probably the best player on
the team everything is gonna go through
him
basketball it's my medicine just helps
me to get away from my problems for a
little bit it's our stress reliever
just play basketball when I put that
Jersey on I try to carry the tradition
for the people that already built it
we're just trying to keep this legacy
going all right so let's go out there
and let's have some fun and give these
guys a show the fans like with Winnebago
really it gets crazy they're loud
they're yelling I mean this is it's a
great atmosphere the fans come to watch
because that they see how hard the boys
work on the clip one today goes a very
special place
[Applause]
[Music]